Let's go next to our caller from the 5 7 4
area code who's calling today from 5 7 4.
Hi, Brittany.
Hey, Brittany, what's up?
I was just wondering, do you have any advice
for someone whose family is completely pro-Trump?
Personally, I'm not an all of my family.
Is there more on the abuse side of the approach,
ropers?
Oh, what do you mean by that?
Are they abusing?
Well, me, if I say or do anything, they come
at me and act like I'm the bad child and I'm
doing all the wrong things in supporting the
wrong things and all that.
Oh, my goodness.
What state what state is this all happening?
But it just kind of country, Indiana.
OK.
And so your entire family is very much pro-Trump.
And then you'll introduce an alternative to
that, so to speak.
And they will attack you.
Yes.
And even if it's like my site, extremely way
more logical, like the illogical mass comes
out, and then that's when the abuse of wordage
and such comes out.
Can you give me an example of what how they're
how they're verbally abusing you?
Basically, in all this, you know, like, well,
you're stupid.
You don't you don't know what you're talking
about.
It's all along the lines of, you know, you
don't follow the family, you're not Christian
enough.
Oh, my God.
Yeah.
Is this evangelical Christianity?
Yeah, kind of like I like to refer them as
the Bible beaters, not so much of the going
to church, but they promote that.
And if you don't go, you're a bad person.
And when this happens, is this like parents
as siblings?
Cousins, what, like generation relative to
you, is it?
Parents mostly.
Wow.
Wow, that's tough.
I mean, listen, it ultimately the answer is
really in you in the sense of what do you
want your relationship to look like with these
family members, right.
Because I could give you advice that would
smooth things over.
But to make you feel like you're repressing
your thoughts, which isn't good.
I could give you advice that would be very
confrontational where you would feel like
you're getting your thoughts out, but it could
ruin your relationship with your parents.
So really.
You know, I'm not well positioned to tell
you what how to handle it.
It's really about figuring out what is it
that you want this relationship to look like,
because, you know, I mean, at a certain point,
you've got to.
You may have to choose do I want a reasonable,
superficially reasonable relationship with
my parents were deep down, you're extremely
frustrated or do you want to risk them potentially
shunning you?
It almost sounds like in order to get your
points across and nobody can answer that other
than you, Britney.
Yep, I agree.
Sorry to hear about the situation.
I mean, it really sounds horrible.
It's not fun.
But now I appreciate your show.
It gives me smiles and makes me feel better.
So thank you.
Thanks, Brittany.
Really great to hear from you.
And let us let us know how that all how that
all shakes out.
That's not not a good situation whatsoever.